okay let's see where you're at with
understanding the path
now there's three identifying marks
of aikido
three you're
if you're not doing these three
you're not doing ikea
okay
who can name
them or one of them
reconciling yin and yang no
takamusa
okay
so
it is the reconciliation
of aikido form with aikido non-form
okay
that's the third one that i list
the first one before
no
cocoon
kokyu and ike are internal aspects right
so do you mean the that like the the
skill in koku and hiking yes so skill in
the internal aspects of the art
okay that's number two
so if you
if you do not
gain that skill you're not doing aikido
okay so meaning you can do
you can do uh
aikido as any jiu jitsu you can do it
externally
if it's not aikido
some jiu jitsu
they're all external
okay but aikido has an internal aspect
to it
what's the first thing and the most
important one
no
non-contestation
is an identifying mark of all jiu-jitsu
all jiu-jitsu have non-contestation and
in fact every single martial art has
non-contestation right even
even um
even the military arts okay there's a
mitigation of risk it's only the the
civilian
who has the fantasy of
overwhelming with superior firepower
do you see that it's always better to
have superior firepower but to use it in
a way that you mitigated risk that is
much better
use of superior firepower
do you get it so for example uh
i i have tanks uh and i can charge up
this beach against all of your uh forces
and stuff but it would be much better if
i flank you with these tanks do you see
that and so
even in that context you mitigate for
the reduction of risk okay so that's
non-contestation is how you mitigate for
the reduction of risk and so it's only
the fantasy
of video game mentalities that you keep
resetting and that
denying the reality that people are
dying because you keep freaking trying
to overpower someone
do you understand that
so non-contestation
is is really just a martial strategy but
it is a mark of all jiu-jitsu
okay so aikido does have
non-contestation because it is a
jiu-jitsu in it um it does do it
externally but it also and predominantly
does it internally through ikea and
cookie okay
well then the first one is the mystical
state okay skill in
gaining
and maintaining the mystical state
what is that what is that okay well
it is what has been spoken about for
centuries throughout the
history of human beings across cultures
okay so in modern terms
uh
we are going to say that it is the
ability
at will
regardless of environment or
circumstances
to deconstruct
the what we call the first mind aspect
so that ego tripartite when you do that
what we call the second mind aspect
kicks it
that is the mystical state it it what is
it it's not the first mind aspect it's
not dichotomy it's not fear right it's
not preference and avoidance it's just
is
there's no
sense
of the subject object dichotomy because
there's one more dichotomy that goes
away
it's not i don't move the sword the
sword moved
okay
so again the three marks of this art is
the mystical state
skill in kokunaiki
and takamusaiki
skill and koku and nike require the
first mind aspect to be deconstructed
you can't you cannot do it
you can talk about it but you can't do
it or you can make it now external so
it's all about leverage
but that's not it
and takumusaiki is the same thing you
cannot do
the reconciliation of form and non-form
from the first mind aspect it cannot
happen
you can't do forms at the speed of life
in combat the form just is
so towards the cultivation of these
markers
we do all kinds of practices
in the dojo
that are aimed towards the
deconstruction of the first mind aspect
the deconstruction the cessation of the
ego tripartite
so we have etiquette
we have the sensei dashi relationship
we have meditation
we have service
servitude practices
do you see
we uphold
the virtues of humility
and valor
faith
do you see
and we culturally
shame
pride
fear
all forms of disengagement retreating
cowardice
right if you think about it we're not
like
loser
but a glance from me when you did it
is enough to go
no
do you understand it's it's a shame
it's a old tool of cultivating virtue in
human beings so you have to have both
the lesson and the
negative lesson so shame is what you
call that
but we also have some some very but you
mine wants to see
almost different from all those other
practices
so what your mind wants to see is some
very direct ways
of gaining
koku and niki
or
takamusu aiki because then they'll work
on the technical things
okay but i'm telling you you you're
better off you
you're better off
prioritizing these other practices
because they go deeper
because they have less
allowance for deviation
then working on
technical things
but
our technical curriculum is lined up
towards
these three markers okay
and they are the following you have to
have kihon wasan
and kihon mazda is
a ritual
for everyone does their prescribed role
it is pure prescription
but it's prescription in those three
markers
you see
so it's not any kind of ritual it's an
as if ritual you're going to do the
technique as if
you have access to the mystical state as
if you have koku and aiki and as if it
is a reconciliation of form and non-form
from there we have micro drilling
when micro drilling we're going to take
segments or sections out of the kihon
waza to focus in on those parts only but
we're doing it for the purposes of those
three markers
so for example
in the last class
they're trying to check our hip as we're
going from
clearing the guard to side control right
and
your ego tripartite wants to push back
on what's pushing on you
you cannot
deconstruct it
you're in an antagonistic relationship
with the person
that you're trying to control because
you're trying to control them
so what we did is we just pulled that
part out
and we said let's see you
release
from this
antagonism
toward what end toward deconstructing
the ego tripartite and getting yourself
out of this dichotomous reality
we just focused on that
and with the with the goal as i said
if you're doing it right an observer
would never know that they pushed on me
do you remember that
you you don't
you wouldn't see it because i never
contested it
you would think he's letting me buy
you see
those are micro drills but they're aimed
towards these three markers
the next level because you're moving
towards those three markers so for
example you're moving towards takamusai
the next level is what i have landed on
called intensified
kihon masa
it's something different than the first
one
in the first one it's an as if ritual
intensified kihon waza is really a kind
of jihuaza
where
you don't really have a naga and uke
although you will recognize the nagin uk
rules from the kimon masa but you don't
really have a nage
you have one person
who is trying
to knock the other person
out of being able to do the form
and that other person is trying to
knock the other person
out of being able to do the form
it is in a way a kind of competition
but you can only compete
with the two sides of the form
do you understand okay
so
some of the ways it comes up at first is
you're going to increase the speed and
the strength of the moose
okay
but you're going to find that when you
get with someone's skill that can
actually do the form
you're going to need these other aspects
you're going to need that mystical state
you're going to need the i can cook you
you get it because you'll just lose over
and over and over again okay
so again to
summarize
you're both competing
against each other
but with the form
with the goal of knocking the other one
out of the form
okay and this this requires that you
start freeing yourself from the form
and that is going to require
that your first mind aspect is
deconstructed
okay
some other things come up
that don't come up in quinoa maza
if you're doing kiwi masala incorrectly
so
when you're in the second mind aspect
there cannot be fear in you
okay
and so
there should not be
contestation in you because that's a
fear response do you understand
well as we do now
an overt competition if i was already in
a fear state
in kihonza and i was already contesting
because i was existing dichotomously
this is really going to trigger you
and you're going to see the downside
and the inability of the first mind
aspect to function
at speed of life levels at combat
engagement
in combat engagement environments it
just can't function
okay it's always behind it's always
early it's always too far in it's always
too far out do you see and all those are
openings for the other person as they
would be for
an opponent or an attacker
okay
if you're doing it right just like
kihonza
you'll be in the mystical state you'll
be in a kind of ecstatic state
there's a there's a pleasure to it
just like any time in the mystical state
is it's it will become
difficult
and it should be
to want to come out of it
because the whole
world makes sense from there
even this
chaotic environment
of someone trying to hit me
with a stick
okay
and you may get hit with the stick but
you won't experience that the same way
but if you're in the first mind aspect
getting hit with a stick
is going to continue to trigger
the first mind aspect and you will only
get hit with the stick more
that this is how intensified keyhole
maza works
okay
when this happens you can't get out of
the first mind aspect when that happens
in intensified chemo mazda training
you should be motivated to go back to
kihon masa
and
start looking more for these three
aspects
this takamusaiki aspect this internal
aspect and this
cessation of the first mind aspect the
ego tripartite
okay
um
not all of us are there
obviously okay so you always
generally you don't do intensified
quinoa
for a long time and some people
there's no point in doing it
okay
because they're just so far still with
as if rituals okay
but
i think our two advanced people here can
do it without killing you
and you'll see
that that would have killed me
and then we can use it to observe
ourselves
uh through this lens that i just laid
out for you
do you understand
um
you also come to learn some martial
strategies and
tactics
that aren't in not as readily visible in
the keyhole
okay so for example
a
beginner mistake without any combat
experience is you always try to rush
your moves
but when you're competing against
someone you get more juice
out of
slow down their
moves okay
so as you rush your move you don't
preoccupy me
with your
previous move and i'm faster
you get as the opponent so for example
in the machia
you do it half-assed kitty guys is
coming way faster than you can do the
technique
to get it
or another one
angle of deflections
always appear to work
you see
because we always imagine that we're
strong enough to do it
but in in weapons work angle of
deflections are too slow
they're way too slow
it's not just that you if as i always
say if you're strong enough it'll work
it but there's always like as weapons
aren't involved
okay
so you're going to find out that your
your angle of deflections just they
don't work not only because they might
not be strong enough once someone is
trying to knock you out of the form
but
they'll always be too slow
they're always too slow okay
you're also going to see
that the
positioning and weight distribution of
your body
is not as arbitrary as you once thought
it was
because
it will delay
between the moves
okay
and if you can't do your attack
in the middle of my attack
you're not doing your attack
the other guy is going to knock you out
of the form okay
now
you shouldn't let the word intensify
only mean power and speed it doesn't
mean that so as for example if i slow
your move down enough i don't have to
move that fast
do you get it and if i am
trying to move faster than you
i might not slow your mood down at all
and then in terms of relative speed i'm
faster than you do you see so i wouldn't
go with
uh just trying to speed up on power
uh it's all about good technique
okay
so let's uh let me just demonstrate and
you'll see i'm not going my athletic
fastest because it's still
a training environment after intensified
chemo maza we have play
and then you also have guaza okay and
jiwaza has become over time
itself very ritualized but that's kihon
masa
in jiawazee it's like you do you i do me
do you get it it's not you run at me
like this
and then i do these three or four moves
that's not giuwaza okay that's just
kiwan waza
done without breaks between the reps
that's it's not guasa okay gu means
freedom so it's free technique you do
you i do me
got it so after intensified kihon we
still have play and we still have
jihawaza moving us into
uh takamusai
okay so
intensified kimon is still a
ritualized so to speak training
environment
got it
so that's why you are restricted to
defeat with the form and not be defeated
with the form so if you start going off
the rails
that is all we're gonna you're not you
can't do it it won't do what it needs to
do okay
all right so i'll demonstrate some
okay so we're we're again we're going to
now take we did the as this ritual of
keyhole
and we did it embryonic
[Music]
some of the things you're going to
notice is you see there's an angle of
deflection in there did you see it so i
came here
boom
and again that's not going to work
so i'm getting rid of the angle of
deflection that's why i called that
embryonic because that's not machiatos
okay
so i do the move
you know i'll give you some of the mind
that i that i'm thinking okay
um
in my mind
i i want to be offense like i'm not
never i'm not going to trade blows with
him okay
um but obviously he took a strike and i
took his strike but in my mind i'm
shutting him down
you get it from the start okay
so as you i'll do a different mindset
you see how to run backwards
instead i'm going forward
and i smother his strike before it comes
out
[Music]
and you can see the timing too uh the
ski is hitting him
right as he's nearing the end of the
atosh do you get it so he he can't
get out of it so
this this would be uh
incorrect
he's coming up he's going to count him
okay
um let's start there let's go
you can see i'm not going full speed but
it's intensified okay
so
okay so we'll watch you keep going
okay so she she got enough of the suba
and it knocked the sword into rayne's
leg rain cut her leg off okay so you you
have to reconcile that atosh on the
first one here we go and you try to keep
doing that
okay and then but there's a gap
after the atosha and the ski
so you're waiting like kihon
you get it you're going to reconcile
that was you drop your center and you
cami and you're trying to get up
and get out
okay
a little better but the first satosh
sucks
and you could have got her on that sword
better
keep going
you try to get her with the sword
by freeing it
good
she got you
do you understand she brain got you
okay cause you moved in too far you
moved into the into her mind
got your leg again oh you could have
stood up on the end okay
[Music]
good okay so we'll watch again we'll
watch this one it's good just the same
thing
he's he's keeping the offense
the sword never gets out you see it shut
down right at his source
okay
we'll switch rolls
yeah so you see there's no torch
because she's rushing the ski
and the mind got stuck on the sword on
his cut came do you see
do you understand did you she looked at
it even she looked at the sword and your
mind got stuck on the sword
okay but slow is it so i can't slow down
like like kihon
do you understand you can just take
advantage of it
good
he's beating her on the on the uh on the
attack
okay so your your instinct
because your dichotomous is to
uh speed up your
machiatosh
do you get it but and again that's
incorrect slow down his kitty ash
so you have to increase the first attosh
okay
good and the mind has to be fluid it
can't be stuck on the increased
better
but he's still not being checked out
because you're you're slurring to the
skin
and you're you're counting coo
you're you're you're targeting you're uh
tagging shark fins
okay that that ski is not going to hurt
anyone because you're just doing your
arms
hey
look at me i'm the threat
you see i hit you
okay
my mind is is already on i'm not too
informed
you see
so try to try to observe uh how my body
mind changes okay i'm just talking here
this first mind aspect talking here
talking here up in here and you'll
you'll feel it she'll feel it too
[Music]
so you see there was no there's no torch
okay so i don't have to take a kit
do you get it
no i'm just sitting there okay
a little switch
the key on
it's reconciled
right
not here
[Music]
didn't talk
you want to go fast
but that's wrong
go
go full
okay
okay so i'm gonna let her pass that
same exact thing you see
i'll let her pass this one
[Music]
so just like if i'm here and i'm gonna
fight you full i want that fist to be
fast
okay
[Music]
but it's not this
do you see that
and then
she's not taking your kidney
because she has to i mean because she's
prescribed it's because she has to
that's intensified okay
you